[Musique]
bonjour philippe jean marie alphonsine
bonjour bonjour vous êtes candidat aux
élections législatives
vous vous présentez dans le centre sans
étiquette sans éthique alors pourquoi
êtes vous candidat à ce scrutin mais je
suis candidat d'abord parce que je suis
engagé depuis plusieurs années dans le
monde de la vie associative de la
jeunesse j'observe autour de moi le
paysage politique mon pays et je me dis
que il y a une véritable opportunité que
en tant que citoyen je m'engage dans le
monde de politique parce que mon pays va
mal il en main et vous pensez qu'un
citoyen est plus à même de régler
certains problèmes qu'un que la plupart
des membres de la classe politique pas
plus amènes je pense que il faut qu'à un
moment donné chaque individu prennent
conscience de la place qu'il doit jouer
dans la société j'ai observé autour de
moi j'ai compris qu'il y à un besoin
j'accompagne les jeunes depuis plusieurs
années j'observe comme je vous ai dit
mon environnement
martiniquais je pense que quand
j'observe en tout cas autour de moi je
voi notre environnement nous avons un
paysage magnifique la martinique est le
seul territoire au monde a aujourd'hui
prétendre à trois de titres auprès de
l'unesco donc la mer le soleil les
rivières la montagne et j'observe que
mon pays est en grande difficulté malgré
tous ces atouts donc c'est par exemple
que je pense que nous devons utiliser
ses atouts que nous avons le pouvoir
développer non à la fraude ou des jeunes
à la fortwo sony via quels seraient vos
projets prioritaires deux ou trois deux
autres si vous êtes élu à l'assemblée
nationale pour la martinique la bourse
si je suis élue la première chose que je
fais là vos excuses avant de le devrait
entrer dans des dans des projets se
serait de rencontrer l'ensemble des élus
martiniquais des députés de la
martinique pour proposer un projet pour
la martinique donc la première chose ce
serait de 2 proposait de mettre en tout
cas en oeuvre un véritable projet
d'étude axée autour de notre vraiment je
pense qu'il va falloir à un moment donné
que l'on se dise ce que l'on doit donner
aux jeunes donc je pense qu'il faut peut
adapter les études des jeunes à notre
environnement il est le deuxième projet
que je souhaite toujours pour les jeunes
je pense qu'il faudrait penser à ceux
qui partent étudier en métropole
qui malheureusement sont obligés de
revenir ou abandonnés parce que souvent
ils n'ont pas les moyens on a des
parents qui deviennent de nouveaux
pauvres parce qu'il faut payer à la fois
les études puis le logement des jeunes
donc je proposerai au gouvernement qu'on
ait une bourse d'éloignement pour nos
jeunes comme eux non comme pour les
employés qui ont une bourse une prime
d'éloignement donc c'est une des
priorités que je serai de proposer au
gouvernement dès que je serai élu député
et c'est alors si vous êtes élu dans la
circonscription du centre dans laquelle
vous vous présentez quelles seraient vos
priorités pour cette circonscription
alors dans le centre comme on le
constate on a les crs c'est une grosse
problématique alors j'ai entendu
beaucoup de lui dire qu'on va qu'on va
devoir prendre des décisions mais depuis
des années on en est là se pose la même
question on a une grosse situation moi
je pense qu'il va falloir que l'on
négocié avec nos élus de la france
nationale parce que il y a eu des
décisions qui ont été prises sous la
nationale avec des villes qui ont pu
avoir des réponses sur la l'envahissent
leur envahissement des deux dissidents
m'a dit de si polluantes et donc ils ont
trouvé des solutions il va falloir que
nous départements d'outre-mer que l'on
négocié avec et que l'on discute avec
nos collègues députés de la france de la
bretagne et nous allons devoir un moment
donné
rassembler toutes celles et ceux qui
sont concernés ils faire en sorte que
nos politiques nationaux travaillent
avec les politiques d'autres pays comme
le brésil voir dans quelle mesure on
pourrait stopper cette algue depuis
l'océan il y avait des possibilités
qu'est ce que vous auriez a rajouté à
dire aux électeurs je pense qu'il faut
je le dis aux martiniquais ils ont
gratté nicaise qu'il faut de nouveaux
visages il faut que nous puissions être
capable d'oser le changement parce que
je crois que nous avons des politiques
qui ont travaillé comme il pouvait je
pense qu'à un moment donné il faut
permettre à d'autres femmes et hommes de
entrée en politique ici si cet appel que
je lance aux martiniquais aux
martiniquais ce qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'être dans un parti politique pour
pouvoir intégrer cette vie ce monde je
pense qu'il faut au contraire encouragé
cette nouvelle génération qui arrive et
nous encadrer 12 ans nous permettre bien
sûr de faire partie de cette nouvelle
vague politique je suis ambitieux je
suis motivé déterminé pour pouvoir
permettre que la martinique soit
soit mise en avant mise à l'honneur dans
l'ensemble des projets que nous voulons
mettre en place voilà ce que je sais
c'est pas long mais merci beaucoup en
tout cas merci à vous philippe jean
marie en sourcing
[Musique]